i'm ready okay so let's then
start with the second talk today
it's a great pleasure to introduce
kareem shakala
karim is a professor at the university
of michigan
and he's very well known in the area of
uh
satisfiability solving for his
contributions
and he's one of the early contributors
to the idea of
conflict analysis for specifiability
solvers
even though he has already did
some points that credit could go back a
little further but
he's credited for for this concept
back in 1996 and today he's going to
tell us about
symmetry and quantification a new
approach to verify
distributed protocols so please
thank you albert i'm not really sure how
this talk fits into the theme of this
workshop
still i think it's somewhat relevant in
the sense that this describes yet
another application of set
that i find and i hope you will too find
uh quite compelling
uh more than 10 years ago we conjectured
that the interruptibility of
propositional set maybe due in part
to the presence of syntactic symmetries
in the cnf instance
finding and breaking those symmetries we
hoped could provide an additional boost
to cdcl algorithms especially for unset
instances
well that's not how things turned out we
did figure out how to find and break the
symmetries
but failed to see any measurable boost
in performance
the silver lining on all of this is that
we learned a great deal about
permutation groups
came up with the fastest algorithm for
solving graph automorphism
and surprisingly even canonical labeling
we also thought we could even resolve
the issue of where the automorphism
problem fits in the complexity hierarchy
spoiler alert we did not but i'm open to
discuss that with anyone who's
interested
uh you can read all about it in the
updated uh symmetry and status stability
chapter in the second
edition of the handbook of
satisfiability that should be out soon
and that i'm shamelessly advertising
here on my left
uh but here's an application which
abounds with symmetry
it's been tackled by many researchers
over many years
but almost entirely not in the context
of clause learning set
the application is most naturally
encoded in the quantified first order
logic
and has been addressed very recently
using quantified fold reasoning in smt
solvers
but again mostly ignoring its inherent
symmetry
so this talk will show that there is a
close connection between symmetry and
quantification
that was the principal insight that
yielded a simple and elegant solution
this is still work in progress and i
will highlight at the end some of the
open problems that still require for the
research
oops my slide is not
switching now for some reason
yeah it's been all the time in the title
slide
i'm no i i know i want to move from the
title slide and i can't
so let me start it over
all right we tried it in the break and
it worked right
yes okay
technical glitches
i'm gonna stop the share
about that
okay let's share again
and let's do this
okay is it switching now not yet
i need to share the screen again
okay now something is coming up okay
that's the portal now we can do this
and now i can do this
and now it's switching right that's the
second slide i suppose
you see the second slide now okay yes
all right sorry about that glitch
so to set the stage for what i'm going
to talk about today let's quickly review
some of the basic ingredients we need to
solve this
problem given a softer program
a hardware design a protocol spec etc we
encode it as a finite transition system
in some suitable logic
over a set of state variables x we will
use i
t and p to denote the predicate that's
the predicates that specify the initial
state the transition relation and the
safety property
this is the modeling step of model
checking
now the checking step analyzes this
model to either show that p holds
it is violated or it may fail to provide
an answer
now checking amounts to finding an
inductive invariant for the transition
system and there are many ways it can be
done
for example starting from i the initial
state we can successfully derive states
that are reachable after one step and
two steps etc
until we find all of the reachable
states r
um at that point we can uh reduce
checking to determining
if i and r satisfy p by showing that the
set queries
i and not p as well as r and not p are
unset
if either of these queries is
satisfiable then p is violated
now typically this is done
using bdds uh but it's not scalable
in general uh because r is in general
intractable to find that way
uh the alternative is to find an
inductive invariant without computing
r okay so in this scenario let's assume
that p holds
ie that r implies p and let's assume
further that there are states in p
that can transition to states that are
not in p
in other words that the query p and t
and not p prime
is set this means that p is not closed
under t
it is not inductive even though it is
safe to make it inductive we need to
find a strengthening assertion call it
a that together with p is an over
approximation of
r and is inductive ie starting from any
state
in a and b we remain in a and b in the
next state
this will yield the inductive invariant
that we are looking for which is
uh equal to amp that proves that b holds
the question is though how do we find
this a and
uh to date the most effective approach
for doing this is incremental in
incremental induction using the ic3 pdr
algorithm
now describing ictpdr is outside the
scope of the star but i will sketch a
bit
later its most important step and so how
we can modify it to
take advantage of symmetry
my group has been developing safety
checking tools for hardware and software
using incremental induction
coupled with a syntactic abstraction
that over approximates data variables
and operations
as we hunt for what we call control
centric bugs
the latest incarnation of these tools is
avr
which was the overall winner of the 2020
hardware mother checking competition and
sorry about this plug
but now that we have a big hammer let's
find a big nail
to hammer and the big nail
came in the form of verifying infinite
state unbounded protocols also known as
parameterized systems this application
was brought to our attention by
colleagues who work in distributed
systems
and who held the view that verification
of such systems
cannot be done using model checking
since it is known
that model checking is quote unscalable
instead some variant of interactive
theorem proving that involves manual
generation of inductive candidate
inductive invariants
seems to be necessary we took this as a
challenge
and proceeded to figure out a way to
prove them wrong
but we needed to understand what
infinite state protocols are all about
and why they are hard to verify verify
algorithmically
so here is the simplest possible example
of an infinite state protocol
it consists of an unbounded number of
servers and clients
the state variables are represented as
relations over the server and client
domains
the unary relation semaphore of s
indicates if server s
is available the binary relation link cs
indicates if client c is connected to
server s
now initially all servers are available
and none of the clients are connected to
any server and here i'm using the
tla plus notation that lamport you know
devised
to describe you know the logic here okay
um the transitions in this protocol
expressed as actions
so connecting client c to server s
requires that the server
is available and if so sets the link
between c and s to true
and the semaphore of s to false this is
viewed as an atomic action that leaves
all other state variables unchanged
so here is the state after executing the
action connect c3
s2 and the action connecting c1
s1 i hope you can see the animation over
here that i spent a lot of time doing
next the other action
is the to disconnect a client from a
server this action requires that client
c
is currently connected to server s and
executing the action
uh causes the link between c and s to be
false and the semaphore to return to
true
this again other state variables are
remain unchanged
um so executing a disconnect c3 s2
results in this state
now the safety property that must be
satisfied by this protocol is specified
by this quantified formula
which basically says that at most one
client can be connected to any server
at any given time it turns out that this
property is invariant
but it's not inductive and adding the
strengthened assertion a given by the
quantified formula shown here
makes it an inductive makes a and b
inductive
proving that he holds the assertion a
basically says that the existence of a
connection between client c
and server s implies that s is
unavailable
so the goal here is to devise an
algorithmic procedure that derives such
quantified assertions
or to show that he fails that's the
problem
now it turns out that this is not a new
problem there's a sizable body of
literature that has examined it over the
years
which basically concludes that at least
for safety properties
the proof of correctness can be
determined by analyzing a small
finite instance which is then
generalized to any size
there are differences in the details but
all previous attacks of this problem are
based on the notion
that the behavior of an unbounded
parameterized system can be inferred by
examining a relatively small
instance of it this is just a sampling
of the literature on the so-called
cut-off methods
so are with our finite state hardware
model checker avr
we proceeded to build the i4 protocol
verification system
our entry into the space was through the
iv language and verifier
developed by ken macmillan when he was
at microsoft research
now he's a colleague of moshe i think in
austin
um not in austin i'm sorry you're a
thrice
the i4 system reads an iv description of
a protocol
and proceeds to create a small finite
instance of it based on a user specified
size this is then converted into a logic
circuit in the viral cardio description
language
which is fed to our verifier avr
if the verification fails avr produces a
counter example
which can then be used to debug the
protocol description
otherwise avr produces a finite
inductive invariant for the given size
which is passed to a generalization
procedure that produces a corresponding
universally quantified invariant this
step is quite ad hoc
since it presumes that universal
quantification is the correct
generalization
of the finite invariant in any case this
quantified invariant is then passed to
the iv verifier to determine if it is
inductive in the embodied case
if it is verification succeeds if not
the next step depends on whether the
property itself
or the assertion produced by avr is the
reason for failure
failure due to the property is handled
by manually increasing the instant size
and repeating the process
failure due to one or more of the
assertions is handled by strengthening
the assertions in another ad hoc
refinement step followed by
running the iv unbounded check we
developed
i4 as a proof of concept for the idea of
generalizing finite invariants
that are automatically generated by an
existing finite state model checker
which was not
so it's not done earlier so how well did
this work
so here's a set of 29 protocols from a
variety of sources
they are similar to the client server i
mentioned earlier in that they are all
based on unbounded sets of distinct
but fully interchangeable and symmetric
elements
i4 manages to solve 13 of them some
fairly quickly
some taking significant time the problem
though is that this result the resulting
invariance
uh in the columns uh labeled inv the
size of the invariant
tended to be quite large compared to
known human generated invariants
this may not seem all that significant
considering that the process is almost
fully automatic
however it is desirable in these cases
to have small invariants that can be
easily understood by inspection
a more serious problem is that i-4 is
not robust in many cases it fails
because of the ad hoc procedures for
generalization refinement
in particular as we see later it fails
on the bottom 11 protocols
because they require strengthening
assertions that cannot be expressed with
just
universal quantification so the rest of
my talk describes how we solved all of
these
issues the solution on what to describe
has been implemented in a tool called
ic3po
which is an extension of ic3 for proving
protocol properties
we just learned that the proper has the
paper has been accepted
for presentation in may at the nasa
symposium formal method symposium
and it will be presented by phd student
aman boyle who is the audience and will
help me answer
any questions that you may have
so i'm going to describe ic3po through
an example that covers most of the steps
it carries out to produce a quantified
strengthening assertion
this example is due again to ken
mcmillan and written in the ivy language
i mentioned earlier it describes a
simple consensus protocol let's go
forward
through it um i will be describing this
in the tla plus language because i find
it a lot more
uh precise so we have
a toy consensus protocol that is based
on three unbounded sets of
constants nodes quorums and values
the state variables are binary a binary
relation vote which is true for a given
node value pair
if the node has voted for that value and
a unary predicate
decision which is true for a given value
if that value has been decided
quorums are defined as subsets of nodes
such that each pair of quarants has an
unempty intersection
i will further discuss forums in a later
slide the protocol has two actions cast
vote
to indicate that node n is voting for
value v
and decide to indicate that the value v
has been decided
on but decided on by the nodes in the
quorum q
again i will elaborate on these actions
a little later but want to highlight
that they are described in terms of some
auxiliary non-state
quantifieds of expressions i'm showing
them here in green
did not vote and chosen act these
uh the different roles played by these
different variables will be highlighted
in
in my slides by displaying them using
different colors
font colors black for state variables
that's vote
and decision and green for the auxiliary
variables and blue for the actions which
act as
inputs finally i t and p
are given as quantified formulas stating
the conditions in the initial state the
protocol is possible actions
and the required safety property namely
that if a decision is made on two
different values then they must be the
same that's consensus
now the assumptions under all of this is
that the domain constants
are unordered and indistinguishable i.e
each domain is fully symmetric
and secondly the logic underlying this
is quantified first of the logic with
the empty theory we don't do arithmetic
here
uh but before we get into the inner
workings of ictp0 we need to introduce
some notation
uh in order to follow the story so what
i'm showing you here
is in mono font um the
names of the domains node quorum and
value
and if i want to talk about them in the
finite case i would put a subscript so
node sub
3 is a domain of nodes with three named
distinct but interchangeable constants
i'm calling them here arbitrarily n1 n2
and n3
the if i'm talking about a particular
size
instance for example an instance that
has three nodes three quorums and two
values
i will use those as arguments to the
various predicates in the
uh in the transition system so i t and p
on three nodes three columns and three
values are as shown here
now when we generate an inductive
invariant
an assertion i should say we
discover it based on a size instance so
here a sub 332
is an assertion that was found on a 332
instance
and in this case when we apply it to a
332 instance it will be
obviously inductive because that's how
we found it
but we can also take that assertion that
we found on a 332
instance and see if we cannot apply it
to a larger instance
four nodes four quorums and two values
okay and the same thing
uh would be true for the environment so
i'm gonna be talking about this a little
bit later
uh this notation if it's not clear it
should be clear a little later on
now i mentioned that quorums are defined
as subsets of nodes making them a
dependent domain
and the domain over here let's say is a
node domain of
three nodes so there are eight subsets
of three
and a quorum on these that satisfies the
non-intersection
uh axiom would probably be this
there are others but you know this is
the one that actually covers all of the
values
of node three now this is actually a
very clever way to specify majority
right uh but to add also symmetry to it
we can just pick these three subsets of
two elements each
that are symmetric majorities and we can
call them
e12 q13 and q23 and
essentially infer a quorum set that has
only three
forums in it that correspond to the
three nodes the number of quorums will
obviously depend on the number of nodes
it's basically n choose n over two
ceilings something like that okay so the
number of quorums will increase
as the size of the node set increases
now
when we talk about symmetry we say um
there are some permutations that leave
the object
we're talking about invariant here we
have full symmetry if we have an odd
uh sort of three or three nodes
there are six symmetries six
permutations
that should leave everything the same
and we can then look at the
uh action of that symmetry group on the
forums for example so the quorum one two
would then permute as shown here
and we look at the other quorums and
they will permute as well
um finally what i'm trying to do with
this one here is to show that
denote permutations induce permutations
on the quorums as well but
the quantum permutations have to follow
the node permutations for consistency
um now a little bit about me so when i'm
confronted with a problem that's outside
my knowledge base
i always find it helpful to encode it
into something that my brain can process
and my brain is wired to process logic
circuits so
in the next few slides i will show you
uh
some circuit diagrams that represent
this protocol so here is the first one
this is the circuit diagram that
corresponds to the action of casting
vote casting a vote by node one to value
one
we have a flip flop here that is the
state variable node vote of
n1 v1 and it will become true
if the following condition is satisfied
that we have a
cast vote n1 v1 and that node 1 has not
voted before
so that signal here in green is like a
wire in a combinational circuit that
says
um for all v uh i did not vote for any
value node one has not voted for any
value
um we can then repeat this for other
values v2 and v3 and for other nodes so
that's
the action of casting a vote the action
of deciding on a value
is a bit more involved so here again we
have a flip flop
towards the right that is saying here is
the decision on value one
and that decision to value one uh the
decision becomes true value one is
chosen
if the following condition is satisfied
that the enabling condition on that
marks
uh so let's look at that uh we have i'm
not sure if i can use my cursor here
suppose that uh all the nodes in quorum
1
2 which are notes n1 and n2 have
voted for value 1 then we can then
uh decide to make decision on value one
true
okay and here what i'm showing is a
signal
again a combinational signal that says
all nodes in this quorum
have voted for this value and so we can
then make the decision that value
but there are other choices for how to
make that decision
and because there are other forums so
this output of this or gate is there
exists a forum
such that you know all members of that
quorum voted for that value
so we put all of this together and then
we have this whole circuit diagram
that describes the logic circuit for the
protocol with three nodes three forums
and three values
um this part here is the part that
updates the states of votes
and this part here is the state is the
part that updates the state for
decisions
and the last part is the property that
says only one of those decisions can be
true
for the property to hold now
based on the theorem the ancient theorem
that a picture is worth a thousand words
this picture very clearly converts the
inherent symmetry of the protocol
we have heard in several talks over the
past several weeks
that understanding instance structure
may be key to explain the
complexity defying performance of cdc at
solvers
but what you're looking at here is
structure galore
it does not need much effort to expose
it
okay but we also need to look at
equations
and this is the definition of the
transition relation for this protocol
um for a three three sized instance
three nodes three forums three values
it corresponds to a formula
a conjunct a of 18 uh literals
uh nine forecast vote and nine for the
site
um the question now is can we uh what
what happens if we permute this
uh uh formula using
and i need to move my
never mind i cannot see the permutation
on my screen
unless i move this yeah suppose that we
apply the permutation shown here
on the right which is i'm gonna map n
one to n three and three to n two and
into back to n one
corresponding quorums uh map uh uh
as shown earlier and i will also map v1
to v2 v2 to v3 and v3 to v1
this is just one permutation of these
symmetric domains
what happens if i do that so let's take
the first
disjunct here which is
ah this always happens i think when i
touch
when i touch zoom i need to stop this
now
excuse me and restart it
we need software to verify this
we're seeing the same thing yes
but now i think you can see the
animation now it's
the animation is coming up yes yes
there's a there's a bug between
zoom and powerpoint and you know windows
and you know everything
so it's basically yeah we take exactly
we take vote n1v1 and we apply that
permutation so n1 becomes n2
and i'm sorry n1 becomes n3 according to
that permutation
and v1 becomes v2 is that a new
literal no it is actually that one
we can take another uh disjunct say the
bottom one here
decide quorum 2 3 v3 we permute it we
get the side q1 v1
it's another disjunct and in fact when
you apply
all of this you discover that t
and in fact i and p are invariant under
all permutations of the domain constants
this is what we mean by the symmetry
with respect to these domain constants
so now i'm going to take a slight uh
detour into
it's describing what's happening in ic3
because ic3 is our
tool for discovering these uh in
variance
so suppose that we are in the middle of
finding a
conductive invariant and we have so far
found that there is a counter example to
induction
ending in an up and not b basically and
we are at frame i plus one
where we found that there is a cube s
that is
the beginning of this uh partial
execution that ends up in not b
um and the question that we want to ask
is uh if
can we eliminate this because you know
it's not reachable from an earlier frame
so we issue the uh query f i n t
and s prime is that satisfiable if it is
satisfiable then we have to continue
going back
and perhaps end up reaching i and then
showing that there is a counter example
but in this case it is unreachable right
it's unset
so we can block it in frame i plus one
meaning we move the frame this way this
is done by essentially negating the cube
to create a clause not s which we then
add
to frame i plus one this is basically
how the process goes in
incremental induction so now let's look
at a specific
uh cube s in this front in the context
of our
um our example here so the cube here is
s equals vote n2v1 and vote n2v2
it's unreachable so we're going to
create a clause which is the negation
and then we say is that the only clause
that we can
actually learn at this point um since
this clause has equivalent symmetry
equivalent
clauses to it let's see if we can find
all of those
so we have uh nodes and we have values
in this clause
let's permute the clause on nodes
and so we get the stable of permutations
uh
only uh the so the note permutation
basically
either generate new clauses that are
distinct or they just
uh reorder the literals in the clause
in this case we see that um we we end up
with three distinct
clauses here uh in fact one of them is
uh talking about n1
another is talking about n2 and another
is talking about n3
we can take them each at a time and see
if we can
then permute the values something
similar happens over here
we get three versions of this clause on
node one when we permute the values
and we do the same thing for the other
two
long story short this original original
clause that we started with that was
talking about node two
with voting for v1 and v2 has
eight symmetric equivalents so we have
an orbit of that clause
that is nine clauses long
now this allows us then to boost the
uh learning so we start with this
cube which has these equivalent
cubes that if the solder happened to
pick one of them you know we would have
gotten a similar
a similar result here in fact these
similar cubes to s
behave the same way they reach
f i plus one and they cannot be reached
from f i
so we can learn all of them at the same
time okay
this will tremendously speed up the
convergence
and we can learn all of the same time
but more importantly than that
is that we can use this orbit
to infer and a quantifier that describes
all these nine clauses at the same time
this is done syntactically i don't have
time to explain it in this talk
um it's in the paper and it would be in
the presentation in may
but you can look at the syntactic
structure of that clause and
that's highlighted here and say all
of its orbit can be described by this
quantified formula
for all n for all v1 v2
if the v's are distinct then it implies
the clause
which you can turn it around and to say
for all n
for all v1 v2 if i voted for v1 and v2
then v1 must be equal to v2
just trust me on this one that this is
done syntactically now
to prove that it is actually the same we
can
instantiate this quantified formula it's
got three nodes in it a variable on
three nodes
and two variables on three values so
there's 27 instantiations
a lot of them end up being true because
the consequent v1 equals v2 is uh
is false is true i'm sorry uh when when
when the
when the instantiation of the two
variables v and v2 are the same
and a lot of the others are redundant so
anyway
you end up after doing this discovering
that
this table of instantiations is
identical to the closed orbit
so the quantified formula is an exact
compact representation of the closed
orbit that's an important
kind of point to make here let's take a
look at another
clause this one has not decision on v3
and then we have three similar looking
literals chosen at q1 2 v2
and q13v2 etc so we can do we
do the same thing we can we have to
permute the values we permute the values
and we end up with three distinct
versions of this clause
one on v1 one on v2 and v3
but now when we try to permute so we can
describe this with just
so the quantification of the uh
variables on different sorts on
different domains can be done
orthogonally
because they are not permutable across
these domains the values cannot be mute
with nodes and the foreign mutual values
so we can these three clauses the
distinct ones can be described with this
quantified formula on values
and then if i try to permute the quorums
let's look at permuting q13 and q23 here
and it changed the order of the last two
terms
but it's the same clause so we did not
create a new distinct clause here
and in fact if you try the other
permutations of forums you
do not just discover any new uh uh
clauses
so permuting the quorums here did not
change the
clause and that is because we have all
of them remember we have a quorum of
three
and a quorum uh set of three forums
and all three forums are appearing uh
identically in this
in this clause so we end up um
um with the same clause and we can then
summarize it with an existential
quantifier on quorum
so this now is for all v in value
not this decision on v or exists forum
such that etc so this naturally
just falls out from doing the symmetry
and if you substitute for
uh the definition of uh chosen at
uh you get this rather interesting uh
uh formula that has quantifier
alternations for all on value
existing quorum for all unknowns we
didn't have to do anything special on
this this was all done syntactically
okay now
any questions about this maybe i i
should ask is there any question about
this
so far
you can ask questions in the chat or um
yourself
and if not you can continue i can
continue so i have chosen to illustrate
symmetry boosting and quantifier
inference using these two clauses
because they i end up being in the uh
final strengthening assertion
okay but this process is done throughout
the incremental induction
these are the ones that survive at the
end and so this is now the invariant
that we have discovered
on a 33p instance okay here is the
property
here is the uh first strengthening
assertion
and here's the second one okay
and the idea was why did i choose three
notes three columns and three values you
know what was special about those
and now the answer for notes and quorums
is easy
because if i had that domain of just two
nodes i would only end up with one
quorum
and since the protocol seems to want to
talk about two forums and none
intersection and so on
to get two columns i need at least three
values but the question is harder to
answer for values because i
i only see two values in the thing that
i'm doing over here
um and so why not just try with two
values
so let's try it with two values so this
now shows the invariant that we get
when we derive it from an instant that
has three nodes three forums and two
values
and it is kind of like the previous one
except for this one here
where the first strengthening assertion
looks different
it's got an exists v in the
version of two values and it's got uh
for all on the on the other one so which
is correct
um well the only way to answer this
question is to test it out
so here i'm showing the uh domain of
nodes you know as i increase the number
of
uh nodes and the domain of values the
quorums
are dependent on nodes so we don't have
to show that you know we don't have to
have a three
d diagram here so if i run a
experiment on three nodes and two values
and i discovered this
invariant that i just showed you the
question is is this gonna
generalize to any size uh and we can do
it here i'm saying multi-dimensional
induction in course because i want to
ask a question of
the experts in the audience a little
later as to what to call this because
i'm not sure what to call it
so we're gonna fix the values to two and
increase the notes
to four and the quorums to four and
check it
on that size instance so check the three
three two invariant
on a larger size instance that has four
notes and four quadrants
and it's it checks it's inductive but if
i
try to do it on keep the number of notes
and columns the same but
increase the number of values from two
to three it doesn't check it's not
inductive so i know that it's not going
to generalize
so how about then increasing the number
of values to three
and try that trying that again and if we
do this now
we will discover that first set of
invariants that i showed you the
strength assertions i showed you earlier
and if we increase the number of nodes
it checks if we increase the number of
values it checks
and so it looks like we've got what we
needed right
we derived an invariant on a 333
instance
that we can now claim is valid for any
size instance
now you might think there's something
fishy going on over here okay
here's mathematical induction i don't
have to spend time explaining this okay
we gotta think that we're gonna prove
for all uh
n greater than or equal to v where b is
our base
and so we need to show that it's true at
b and then we have to show that it's
true for
every k greater than or equal to b to
show that for every k greater than or
equal to b if it's true at that k
it's true at the next k so
it looks like this right we cannot say
anything before b
but we can say it's true for everything
at b or greater
now what we're doing here is i'm
simplifying here with a single domain
we have an invariant that was derived on
a
size b instance and applied to size b so
it's true by
uh so it's it's invariant by definition
it's inductive by definition so this is
my side b it's in
based on b applied to b and uh it's
inductive
and then i increase the domain size to b
plus one but i keep the
clause the clause here is what i call um
fisa b the c fisa b is based on just
an instance of size b so that didn't
change
and so and and and we find that this
second one isn't that is inductive
so all we did is we showed that it's
true at b and we showed that if it's
true at me it's true at b plus one not
for all
a greater than equal to b and then we
conclude that it's true for all
n what is this i'm calling it symmetric
induction but if somebody has a better
idea
or what's going on it's correct
empirically but we haven't really proved
it yet
so i'm almost done here um
we ran ic 3po on all the 29 protocols i
showed you earlier
and besides comparing it against i4 we
compared it against two verifiers that
perform
quantified fol reasoning updr which
tries to infer universal inductive
invariants and
fol ic3 which uses logic separators to
infer both universal and existential
inductive ingredients
i'm showing here the 18 protocols were
proof
whose proof did not require existential
quantification and the drive
strengthening assertion and the most
significant bit here is that ictp all
solds all of them
in the least amount of time and this
performance is generally predictable
okay now uh the remaining
uh the results for the remaining 11
protocols whose proof requires
invariance with both universal and
existential quantifiers
are shown here and since the only
meaningful comparison is between ic3po
and
folic3 i'll remove the results for i4
and updr so i'm going to get rid of
those
and then i'm going to tell you about
these symbols i have here the symbol
it says that the ic3po assertion that
was found
includes qualifier alternations this one
says that it has auxiliary variables
and this one shows that the formula it
produces is an uh
fol formula that is not an epr it has uh
uh qualifier alternation cycles so
except for the two protocols for two
protocols ic3po
is quite fast in several cases much
faster than folic3
it also solves all eleven protocols
while folic3 solves
nine in all cases it produces a smaller
invariant
on average less than a third the size
and almost the same size as the human
generated invariant
one statistic that seems to show an edge
for folic 3
is that the number of s t poles it uses
is
is the number of smt calls smaller than
ic 3po
which is skewed by just the last
protocol but we must keep in mind that
this is an apple sub oranges comparison
because
the snt calls in ictp0 are
quantifier free whereas in the one in in
folic3 they are quantified
so these are obviously observations that
must be taken with a grain of salt
because they're in the context of this
particular set of protocols
but it seems that inferring the
quantifier shape
based on sim and simple statistics
simple syntactic
symmetry arguments gives ictpo an
advantage of producing
with very little effort compact
invariants
that if necessary include complex
quantifier alternations
that other approaches struggle to find
so this connection between symmetry and
quantification is a perfect example of
looking at the problem structure in this
case symmetry and seeing if it can lead
to a simple efficient and elegant
solution
okay so um i'm almost done a couple
weeks ago my sidekick aman
introduced me to the world of smart
contracts in particular this cardano
multi-signature protocol that looks very
much like the protocols we saw earlier
you don't need to dwell on the details
this is just another parameterized
transition system
defined on a set of unbounded symmetric
domains
it has a transition relation captured by
this diagram it has several safety
properties specified
so amman read the papers describing this
protocol which tells me
which he tells me it's also used in
bitcoin and ethereum and so on i don't
know much about this stuff
he put it in tla plus and then icp on it
obtaining these two strengthening
assertions in about 30 seconds
so i'm gonna switch now my browser and
show you something
um so with this
stop and the slide show
and the slide show how does it end the
slideshow here okay
and
and then show you this screen now
do you see the screen now so
uh we don't know do you see the screen
yeah sorry i was meet yeah we can see it
uh it's got a lot of colored text in it
lots of text
so the the the the smart people at the
uh cardano actually proved this using
their own theorem proverb uh called agda
and so we don't understand really this
i'm just showing you this to show you
that
perhaps we can actually automate this
okay that that's kind of the idea is
modern checking can still probably work
on this so now i can go back to my last
slide here
and uh share screen
on this
and
not not from the beginning no no don't
do it from the beginning
too many clicks here
no
i need to go to the end here
that was a bad idea to switch um
okay so we're gonna do it from here
and switch it
so um i sketched basically the idea the
basic idea behind
compact modified strengthening
assertions for protocols
by syntactically boosting a learn clause
to its symmetry orbit and syntactically
encoding that orbit with a quantified
clause whose quantifier shape
includes the required universal
existence essential quantifiers
i also sketched a
symmetric induction procedure that
converges
but i'd like to discuss that and we have
good
encouraging validation on this
experimentally
i necessarily get some details such as
various optimizations
and also the approach can be extended to
other things other than symmetry
and finally you know i am working with
one of the um
uh smartest uh simon's fellows catelyn
fosekis
to see if we can show the decidability
of quantified for reasoning when the
domains are symmetric fully symmetric
she's making very good progress on that
um if you're interested
the paper and the code for fic-3po is
available online
and now i will stop and uh happy to
answer any questions we have or
delegating the
question to a man if i can't find the
fact if i don't know the answer
thank you very much thanks for everyone
so we have time for questions
either for karim or for his student
i have a question yes go ahead
so i'm missing something in the big
picture so the problem
of uh this kind of protocol verification
is
is known for many years to be
undecidable unbounded protocols
so are you attacking an unsolvable
problem
or is this a fragment that somehow is
decidable
that's what i missed here um thanks for
that question that always comes up you
know there is always in every
one of those papers about parameterized
protocol they refer to the two-page
paper by apt
saying showing undesirability of
parameterized systems
yeah yeah i believe that we are
decidable in the very specific fragment
of
uh domains that are completely symmetric
and we don't have interference between
them
so that's what we're trying to show that
even that that for that very specific
class that it will be decidable
so i think we need to separate you know
the the efficiency issue with this
bigger question is this have we
identified an interesting decidable
class
because this kind of undesirability has
been kind of dogging us
and people have tried to identify
decidable classes but the challenge is
to make them decidable and still
interesting
and so i would try to encourage you to
try to
to nail it you know have we find an
interesting
but decidable class for protocol
verification
so we're just scratching the surface
this is new to terrain for us
and a lot of the protocols that we've
looked at
um you know i mentioned in the future
where we're looking at there are other
things
besides symmetry domains for example
paxos which is uh the lan port consensus
protocol
has symmetric domains but it has also a
an order domain called a ballot
which uh we are working on to see if it
can fit
within this uh uh um kind of
subclass if you will um we believe that
it still will remain decidable but
i can't really say for sure i'm not a
theoretician so i really am leaning on
people who are more smart than me in
theory you see if there is a check
actually a class of problems that is
large enough to be interesting for which
we can show this ability
but i'll give you a slogan to try to use
stealing form stealing from hall
inside every unbounded protocol there is
a bounded protocol
wishing to be to be born
you know tony hall said inside every
large program there is a small program
trying to
to be born so we can take a variation of
it
i mean the thing that i really feel a
little weak on is showing that
conversions that we're showing because
of symmetry there's a notion of
saturation
that as you increase the bound you don't
see new behaviors
so there is a connection between
symmetry and induction
and uh you know i think looking at that
would be very interesting
okay there's some discussion going on in
the chat uh
william schultz asked whether the
benchmarks for ic3po
you presented are multi-threaded
are the underlying algorithms
parallelizable uh
this is a question for a man a man can
you unmute and speak
yeah he wrote an answer but it would be
nice if he put on mute
yes so these benchmarks are represented
not as executable programs
but as abstract state machine
descriptions
in quantified first order logic in a
domain-specific language called iv
it is much like tla plus so basically
it's at a level uh higher at the
protocol level and not
at a system level implementation level
so but uh
it is it could be thought of we can
extract a state machine out of it and uh
executable c code as well there is some
work on that
but not directly
thank you aman any other questions
um so i have a comment following moshe's
um
question uh we did look at this
this problem is space for a while and
our conclusion our partial results so
far is that
uh the connection between symmetry and
um the existence of an invariant is sort
of related to ashcroft invariants which
are these kind of old notions
of invariance in you are universally
quantifying over
thread ids and concurrent programs but
it could be kind of component ideas
in in distributed systems
but in terms of desirability the the one
decidable
interesting decidable stop fragment that
we found where monadic
proofs so if you you want universal
universally quantified invariants that
the predicates involved in them only
relates the local state of a process to
a global
um to the global state so they're
monarchic in this sense
then you have decidability beyond this
the rest of these liability results
are of the type of boundedness family
tree with things like that that
do not correspond syntactically to the
to the actual processes we cannot kind
of link them
but we can link them to to the shape of
the invariants
uh which is unintuitive in some sense uh
would i appreciate any uh
links to uh some of this literature i'll
i can send you one on
uh on discord thank you
um i i think so every time i
i i hear uh moshe you know every time i
hear undecidability
it seems like you know that's the end of
the discussion no no no that's not what
i meant at all
i mean look we are trying to solve
intactable problems in general
so i'm perfectly okay i just want to
understand it's okay to say we have a
practical approach you know right i mean
byron cook has done all this work on
termination right so it's okay to have
real working algorithm an undecidable
problem that's not a problem
by the way all of these were done where
were actually verified
in the unbounded case so all of the
things that were found in a bounded case
turned out to be actually valid in the
unbounded case as well
any other questions
to have one question myself if i may you
alright
yeah so one word that you always i mean
i'm not an expert in in
symmetry handling for for solving
but the word that people use is symmetry
breaking and
you were using here symmetric boosting
and in some sense you want to exploit
the symmetry
to get more inference
instead of instead of breaking the
symmetry and then
cut the space in some way right so are
these two approaches
do all of one another or are they uh
okay so that's one question i have and
if i may ask the second one
so it's that so this is also
trying to understand a little bit when
you do the quantifier inference
when you want to get these invariants
written in first order logic
is the goal to have human readable
invariant or is it more than what you
want is a compact representation to use
in a different
okay in a different mode yeah let me
answer the first question so
symmetry breaking was uh essentially uh
you know invented to solve the
interactability of large
you know uh uh uh cnf set instances
where uh we thought that because of
symmetry
uh you know many uh unset sub trees you
know could be traversed multiple times
unnecessarily so that's why we need to
break the symmetries
and finding the symmetry of the formulas
was a big project i mean that's where i
got myself
into solving you know graph isomorphism
and all of that stuff
um so yes in that case you know you want
to break the symmetries in order to
reduce the amount of surge
uh in this case uh we're talking about
very small
uh instances so you know two three four
five so uh we don't want to break
symmetries here what we want to do is we
want to
uh uh uh infer from them a quantified
form that will generalize to unbounded
sizes to unbound the domain
so having the symmetric clauses all of
them in the orbit so the the
quantification the quantifier
uh uh the quantified formulas are
actually
representing the orbits of any object
that you have in this case the objects
are clauses if you don't have all of
them then you don't
have a quantified form that captures
that okay so that's that
so it's not meant to uh be
just compact i4 did not do this and it
generated
way larger in variants that were very
hard to look at
these ones are because of the symmetry
much smaller and when you look at them
they look like human generated in fact
some of them are better than human
generated
uh because they take advantage of the
structure in the problem
um what was the second question it was
that whether what is the goal of uh
quantifier
inference is it to the goal is to find
a uh uh quantified invariant that will
work
in the unbounded uh domain so yeah okay
yeah okay thank you
we we infer it from a finite instance
and then we converge it to show that it
actually the final one that we get
will be an invariant for the unbounded
case yes excellent
okay thank you very much
okay so we're very much reaching the
time
if there are more questions it's time to
do them
if there are no more questions then i
will ask
everybody to uh upload and thank him
again
so and thank you every everybody for
joining
and keep keep an eye on the schedule for
meeting next week in the workshop and
thank you very much karim again
thank you thank you very much